welcome back to age 20 special
relativity in this section we're going
to talk a bit more about collisions
i've already seen collisions and study
momentum conservation in previous
sections
so here we can have
collisions and we can describe them in
the center of mass frame for example
where the total momentum is equal to
zero so in case of the collision of two
particles the momentum of particle one
plus the momentum of particle two is
equal to zero
we have then we can then describe the
energy and the momentum of the particles
before and after the collision
in the lab frame
the situation is different here
typically we have one particle with some
momentum hitting another particle which
is at rest
but we can also have different types of
collisions we describe or characterize
elastic collisions where the kinetic
energy is conserved and so is the mass
so you can think about
two billiard balls colliding without any
friction in which case you know they
don't change their appearance their mass
everything is unchanged they just change
the direction
the total kinetic energy in this
collisions are perfectly conserved
but we can also have inelastic
collisions and there's two different
kinds so sticky kinds where the mass
after the collision is greater so you
have two particles for example maybe
they stick together with some
you know like
play-doh balls
um and the kinetic energy after the
collision is smaller or you can have
explosive collisions where the mass
afterwards is smaller maybe you start
from one heavy
big object and then it's exposed into
many smaller ones but the kinetic energy
after the collisions is much is smaller
those are also conditions
so here we want to do
an activity and study an inelastic
collision so before we have two
particles there of billiard balls
they're exactly the same and have a
velocity u
um and after the collision the mass is
capital
big mass
um and we want to describe this
collision once in the center of mass
frame and one in the laboratory frame
and so the question now is
uh are the masses and energy cons is
energy conserved in those collisions and
you're going to
describe this in both
both reference frames
so again stop the video here and try to
work this out
i already did this so i discussed before
i you know in in those collision
problems it's always
important to really be clear the
situation before the collision was a the
situation after the condition was b
so i'm
describing this here
first in the center of mass frame where
the x
i'm just talking about the x component
here the x momentum is zero which is
equal to the mass times u times gamma
minus the mass times u times gamma
that's zero
the energy before is two times the mass
times gamma times c square
after the collision the particle is at
rest
the new one particle is the rest and has
an energy large m over at time c square
in the laboratory frame the situation is
different there is x momentum
zero minus m
times u prime this is a different
velocity times gamma of u prime so here
i'm trying to
indicate that this gamma is not the same
gamma as over here this is a gamma where
the velocity is u prime
and the energy is the rest mass
of the particle at rest plus the mass
times gamma times c square of the second
particle
after the collision the particle has
some velocity
u
and so the momentum in x direction is
minus
large m
times u times gamma of u again and the
energy is large m times gamma u times z
square
okay good so now we can use momentum
conservation and find this equation here
and from which we can then calculate
that the large mass
is equal
to two times the smaller mass
okay
so what you find
is
and this is the relativistic mass you
find that as a conclusion that the rest
mass is not conserved the mass of this
big ball is not simply
the mass of the two rest masses or two
times the mass of the rest mass you have
to consider this gamma factor here it's
two times the relativistic mass if you
want
but you also find that the total energy
is conserved in circulation so that the
sum of
m naught gamma times c square is
conserved in deposition irrespective of
how you actually in which reference when
you discuss the problem
i want to close this part of collisions
um with a small discussion of units and
that will become interesting or
important
later on when we look at particle
physics examples
so in particle physics we often talk
about units of electron volt in
collision experiments or mega electron
volts a key electron involves terror
electrons so one electron volt is the
kinetic energy of a particle with charge
e
which is
accelerated in a potential of one
volts so that it corresponds that's the
unit of energy and it corresponds to 1.6
times 10 to the minus 19 joule or 1.6
times the minus 90 kilogram meter square
over
second square
the mass of an electron is really really
small
and those units here are introduced
because the mod is mass small and you
want to have reasonable
numbers to work with so the amount of
the electron is 9.11
times 10 to the minus 31 kilogram
so if you just rewrite the m naught as
equal to m naught c square
times one over c square you find that
huh now we
rewrite this and find that you know the
mass is 8 times 10 to the minus 14 joule
over c square
or in units of electron volts 5 times 10
to the 5 electron volts over c square
which is
0.511 mega electron volts over c square
or 511 kilo electrons overseas square
so when we talk about the mass of an
electron we sometimes approach this with
natural units in which c square is equal
to one and as
you know
just simply say that the mass of an
electron is 511 k kilo electron volts
the mass of a muon
is
um
mega electron volts and and so on and so
on